hey youtubers it's Charlie since we've
all probably had a few minutes to
process the Jessie Heisenberg Lex Luthor
news I thought it was time to talk about
the top five reasons why this is gonna
be a good thing
and kind of do a breakdown of what it
might mean for the story so many big
things going down this week you know
first Peter Capaldi gets a new suit now
Mark Zuckerberg is Lex Luthor there's
even a bunch of Super Bowl trailers
coming on Sunday I'm actually gonna be
doing videos for most of those so be
sure to subscribe to get all that stuff
too so much comic book stuff happening
right now whether you love or hate the
idea just the Eisenberg is not gonna be
a main character in this so don't freak
out too soon the real big players are
gonna be Ben Affleck and Henry Cavill
they'll be the main characters they're
gonna be each other's villains in the
movie Lex Luthor is just gonna be a
background player so let's get going
here's the top 5 reasons well he's
actually a good choice for the character
number 5 he's actually the right age
based on DC Comics Canon Lex Luthor and
Superman are almost the same age in the
current version of the comic book story
Jesse Eisenberg and Henry Cavill were
both born in the same year obviously all
those push-ups make henry cavill look
just a little bit older though number 4
this will be a background role only Lex
Luthor is not going to be the main
villain in this movie the main villain
if you considered a Superman movie is
going to be Batman and if you considered
a Batman movie Superman is going to be
the main villain and four minor
characters unconventional casting
choices lead to much more interesting
stories just look at kat dennings in
thor the dark world you know she was a
very minor character but she was one of
the most you know non low-key enjoyable
parts of that movie I mean even Wonder
Woman is a minor character in this film
it's really Henry Cavill and Ben Affleck
that are gonna take the lead they're
basically gonna eat most of the screen
time number three he works really well
in an ensemble cast the social network
which you know he's most known for was
largely in ensemble film the way it was
shot Andrew Garfield was just as big a
star if not bigger now then later
Eisenberg was actually able to hold his
own on screen against a post Avengers
Mark Ruffalo
yes Ben Affleck is a much bigger a
Lister than anyone he starred with
before but this all works in the
characters favor
like I said Lex Luthor is just supposed
to be a shadow player in this movie
although he will probably get something
of an origin story number two he has the
dramatic background to play a much
darker version of the character than
we've seen before Gene Hackman and Kevin
Spacey were both amazing actors in the
role but their versions were much more
cartoony Zack Snyder has given Superman
a much more serious tone which demands a
much darker villain but when I say dark
dark without going into crazy Nicolas
Cage ghostrider territory bonus shout
out for the time that Nicolas Cage
almost became Superman and my number one
reason why he's a good choice for Lex
Luthor Mark Zuckerberg is the modern Lex
Luthor in all the previous Superman
stories Lex Luthor was an industrialist
but we're living in the information age
and Lex Luthor is supposed to be this
brilliant if not misguided billionaire
with a really cold personality which
sounds just like Mark Zuckerberg not to
imply that Mark Zuckerberg is evil this
is obviously a comic book villain we're
talking about let me know whether or not
you come down on the you know positive
or negative side of Jesse Eisenberg as
Lex Luthor I'm actually really
interested to see what he's going to
look like in the movie hopefully they'll
release some images of the character
soon obviously we know what Henry Cavill
is probably going to look like that
Superman suit probably won't change a
lot but we haven't seen any pictures of
Ben Affleck yet and obviously we haven't
seen Wonder Woman yet either here's the
breakdown of what the casting might mean
for the story of the movie as well as
the origins of lex luthor character and
the origins of his relationship with the
Superman character let's start with the
Lex Luthor origin he'll be a tech leader
so his rise to power will be just like
Mark Zuckerberg he'll have invented some
tech and then have a shady reputation
for cutting out business partners and
rivals along the way until he eventually
becomes this big billionaire now on to
his relationship with Superman although
they're roughly the same age I don't
think that Lex Luthor and Superman will
have the same shared past that they did
during Smallville or previous versions
of the comic book don't be surprised if
Clark and Lois end up doing a profile on
Luthor for the planet so Superman will
probably meet Luthor for the first time
as Clark Kent not as Superman I predict
much the opposite for his first meeting
with Batman I think that they'll be
meeting for the first time as
superheroes here's some of the best
rumors that I've seen so far but careful
for potential spoilers for Justice
League plot lines and future movies so
the best rumor I've seen says that
during the movie Lex Luthor will buy the
Daily Planet
as a PR move and Batman will end up
setting up the Justice League as a
marvel shield like answer to Superman's
destruction of Metropolis in the first
film consider it like an alternate
reality origin of the league but the
rumor goes on to state that by the end
of the movie Superman will be forced
into exile by Batman and the newly
formed League and the movie will end
before that's resolved leaving any
sequel or Justice League movie you know
whichever comes next to bring Superman
onto the team formally it's just a rumor
but it's the best one I've seen so far
remember Superman and Batman
Argo
to go head-to-head in this movie so they
will not be best buds here's an
interesting question though regardless
of what the plot ends up being do you
think the next movie after this will be
a standalone Batman film for Ben Affleck
or will it be that Justice League movie
in reality it just depends on how much
money the movie makes okay so heads up
like I said this Sunday a whole bunch of
new movie trailers coming including X
Man and Captain America I'm going to be
doing videos for all those be sure to
subscribe to get everything
I'll try and post those on the same
night right now you can click here for a
rundown of what all those trailers are
gonna be and you can click here to get
this week's episode of arrow they just
introduced the red arrow and Oliver to
spend a whole bunch of time training him
it was crazy
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tonight high fives